les auteurs présumés sont de plus en
plus jeunes parfois âgés de moins de 16
ans comment expliquer ces règlements de
comptes ultraviolents un rapport montre
que les affrontements entre bandes de
quartiers différents à paris a augmenté
ces derniers mois les délinquants
d'aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus
violents qui hier surtout les plus
jeunes alors est ce que la délinquance
juvénile est un phénomène nouveau il y
en avait moins avant et bien c'est plus
compliqué dès les années 60 et 70 la
délinquance juvénile est vécue comme un
fléau
n'hésitons pas à employer les grands
mots la marée montante de la délinquance
juvénile ça n'est pas très loin du
cinéma ou la littérature
c'est un trek enregistrant des froides
statistiques officielles de l'éducation
surveillée
il y avait les mobylettes dans la cour
des cités ces jeunes s'ennuient et
résultat on les voit au milieu des blocs
se promenait dès qu'ils ont un peu nos
eaux libres se promener sur leur mobile
était errer comme ça la grande frayeur
de la population les phénomènes de
bandes
tous sont membres d'une bande bien connu
dans le quartier celle des crânes rasés
moyenne d'âge 18 ans les agressions se
multiplient on rançonnent les enfants à
la sortie de l'école et les parents
hopper les vols et âge avez-vous 16 ans
sa demie
pourquoi être ici paul de belay
vous allez le comique c'est une
délinquance qui faisait la une des
journaux
pourtant il n'y avait que 27 mille
mineurs mis en cause par les services de
police ou de gendarmerie en 1960 ils
étaient 240 mille mineurs délinquants en
2016 soit une hausse de 8 100 % fin du
sujet merci à tous et bien non ce n'est
pas si simple vous prévient un des trois
premiers éléments le nombre de jeunes a
explosé entre les années 50 et 70
conséquence si on rapporte le nombre de
délinquants mineurs sur la population
totale des 10 18 ans le pic de
délinquants juvéniles c'était et bien en
1970 ou 7,1 pour cent des mineurs
avaient eu affaire avec la police en
2016 ce même pourcentage est de 3,6 pour
cent donc en proportion
ça a été divisé par deux en 1971 par
exemple les habitants des grands
ensembles se plaignaient de cette
délinquance du quotidien ce sont des
groupes qui circulent dans la cité alors
ça ça roule comme on dit vulgairement ça
roule les mécaniques que ça tienne des
bâtons à bout de bras
ça veut tout casser d'ailleurs salle
c'est pas que ça veut tout gagner c'est
que ça casse tout autre question comment
expliquer le pic au milieu des années 90
c'est la deuxième explication et elle se
trouve du côté des tribunaux en effet
les délinquants sont presque tout le
temps poursuivie en justice depuis 1994
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant cette
année là le taux de réponse pénale dans
les affaires impliquant des mineurs
était de 60 % en 2013 il est de 94% plus
de délinquance aujourd'hui qu'hier
proportionnellement non mais plus de
jeunes démographiquement parlant et
surtout plus de procédures judiciaires
[Musique]